so you opposed giving zielinski 45
billion dollars I do did you oppose him
wearing green Army fatigues when he went
to the White House or everyone was like
people that's I think that he should
have worn a suit who cares I don't I
don't care like they're giving away
they're gutting this first of all I'm
gonna just come out and say it I know
guys I went to the White House I didn't
wear a suit either but that's not the
point the point is I'm not concerned
that a dude showed up not wearing a suit
I know a lot of people are talking about
the decorum of the white house I'm like
bro I'm less concerned about that and
more concerned that they unfurl the
Ukrainian flag and then say Mitch
McConnell's like the top priority for
our power cause to support you cried at
least that's what Republicans think it's
like no that's what you think dude
regular people are kind of like why is
gas expensive when I saw Biden put his
hands on uh zielinski I was like oh I
pictured him thinking and said hello
presidential puppet hello thank you
because he's a puppet they put him up
and they put him in power in 2014 when
they forced a revolution in Ukraine then
they just installed this guy I know
maybe it's not something I will tell you
as a candidate for federal office if you
oppose giving unlimited amounts of money
to Ukraine uh they will call you a Putin
puppet that's right that's like
how dumb is that like Putin's bad the
invasion's bad I condemn it okay it's
like we should look for ways to to get
those two countries to the negotiating
table and we all want to ceasefire right
but remember when Rand Paul just stuck
his neck out and said hi I can't block
this you know I forget it was 40 billion
at the time but if we're going to send
it can we at least get an inspector
General assigned to it can we get a
spreadsheet so we know if this money is
just being wasted or if it's just being
stolen or did you hear zielinski's wife
went on like a shopping spree or
something
40 Grand or something they say if you
want to see who our next enemy is look
at who we're funding right now I keep
hearing that pop up and I'm like wait so
is Ukraine are the Ukrainian Nazis our
next war in six years
off Battalion when Russia uh assuming if
Russia ends up winning for whatever
reason and then all those weapons are
sitting there among pro-russian factions
and they get armed and then start
fighting against us I wouldn't be well
they're not just sitting there there's
also intelligence reports detailing how
there's already a a very uh booster uh
Black Market already in Europe right now
with many of the advanced U.S weapons
being sold to of course criminal gangs
probably jihadists that have that that
now have surface-to-air missiles that
could take down airliners and airplanes
so you know when we're just sending
weapons down there without any
transparency or accountability that
that's a recipe for disaster this is the
same Administration and government that
says it's too dangerous for you to have
a handgun with so many rounds in it but
they're sending surface-to-air missiles
on the black market to Europe right now
which is absolutely mind-boggling here
here's what I think you know that 45
billion dollars I would rather they
spend it on a gigantic sign floating in
outer space that says Vladimir Putin is
a very bad person
because at least it's ours and we're
spending it as we choose instead of just
giving it away to Ukraine to fund a
proxy war granted let's be real it's not
even a proxy war anymore it's just it's
a NATO confident we're really overt
about it they're like they are our
allies here's the Ukrainian flag I don't
know if they said Ally what do you
what's your vision of a ceasefire and
drawdown of the militants in the Ukraine
right now
I mean I think we basically know the the
Contours right it's like I mean so the
problem is Ukraine definitely wants
Russia out of Crimea I don't think
that's in the U.S interest I don't think
U.S is going to force that right uh if
if Ukraine is simply not allowed uh to
join NATO and that's a Line in the Sand
but they can join the EU let the Don
bass have a plebiscite they can figure
out who's going to rule the dawn I mean
I think you could draw this I'm not like
an expert in this stuff but I think you
could draw a peace agreement that gives
Putin some face saving ability to get
out of this thing because it hasn't
worked well for him uh it gives Ukraine
most of what they want and it
de-escalates so that we don't actually
have nuclear missiles flying in six
months it just feels like Biden on you
know on
I don't know I actually don't know how
with it he is right but it feels like
he's kind of just in zombie-like fashion
marching us towards nuclear war yeah I
don't think the chances that are very
low but of course the costs of that are
so high I mean we're talking if the
missiles start flying it's like two
billion people dead in 48 hours well you
can't have that and so why are we even
flirting with pouring more gas on the
fire by sending this money in this
unaccountable way it's a real problem I
don't want to be Cavalier about it but I
fear that if you just put oxygen on it
are we actually threatening to make the
problem worse and no one has been able
to give me a satisfactory explanation
for know why this is super okay and this
is this is de-risking it I just think we
might be adding risk to the system and
it's really complex no we're escalating
it every time we we are every time we do
that we stop the possibility of any kind
of peace deal moving forward and there's
a big possibility of a limited nuclear
war there I think also this conflict uh
allows China to be stronger it allows
them to have more influence especially
with the the the the actions that are
happening because of this war affecting
the poorest people in the world China's
kind of stepping in uh while there's a
big crisis that's been that's built in
there and I kind of wanted to ask you do
you see China or Russia as the bigger
threat to the United States
um because they're also working on crazy
projects with Bill Gates with many
nuclear reactors they're working on a
lot of uh you know technology that we're
not working on here they're they have a
lot of money especially from Western
Elites I see them as kind of a bigger
threat myself what about China's a way
bigger threat this is not debatable it's
like Russia under Putin I think he's bad
you know whatever but but but no it
they're in commensurate right and one of
the risks by the way of just punishing
Russia with so many sanctions you throw
the kitchen sink at them you you they're
West risks pushing Russia into the arms
of China right China would love that
China would love to have Russia as some
sort of quasi-satellite uh State and
this new new alliance new axis against
the West right why would we why would we
do that that we should try to get out of
this war with Russia and Ukraine right
we should try to force them to have a a
ceasefire and then ultimately I think
it's all hands against China
the CCP I imagine you mean yeah CCP what
happens if you can't conflate all of
China with a CCP but actually you kind
of can as long as the CCP is in power
because that's how totalitarianism works
it's important I think it's important to
differentiate between the Chinese people
because they're under that regime as
well sure yeah absolutely basically
modern slaves I look at like eastern
Ukraine I think you mentioned the Don
bass region there's two freeways that go
down into Crimea and I wonder if there's
a ceasefire and we end up there ends up
being like what two freeways are this
this is an interesting philosophy East
97 East 105 those two freeways that go
down into Crimea I mean Russia wants a
land bridge down to Crimea you could
give the Western Freeway East 95 to
Ukraine and East 105 to Russia and just
have some sort of peaceful alignment I
know that zielinski and is it's
Lindsay's very much like Ukrainian
national sovereignty we're not giving up
our land and and period that's it and as
long as if the United States is funding
that message I don't I don't see it
happening I we I think we really need an
American push for a ceasefire but it's a
blockade Russia from the Black Sea makes
no sense like when the Soviet Union fell
apart they gave Ukraine all that land
basically to neuter Russia to make sure
it didn't become another Global hegemon
but at this point it's like yo it is a
global hegemon it's one of the third
most powerful country in the world next
the United States and China probably
um and I think you know I don't know you
make peaceful Solutions
that's me from the outside looking in I
think you just solved that over there is
this in politics I need to go to Moscow
with Lex Friedman as my translator or
and you Luke well you don't speak
Russian right now I don't um but you're
polish there's a big difference between
the two and then I need to go to China
with Jack basobic as my translator and
then they'll have their own translators
that will and they'll be keeping each
other and they're going to give you the
intrusive covet test up your you know
what it happened I would do it I'll do
it if it means Global Peace I'll do it
I'll put it up my butt
you heard it here can we get that uh on
a meme can somebody meme yeah send it to
me for World Peace wow that's that's
very brave of you thanks sir yeah you're
the hero a lot of these conversations I
kind of feel like
we have no idea what's really going on
that these intelligence agencies know
way more about International Affairs
than we do they don't justify or explain
it to us for
reasons of retaining power but also for
for security reasons so we're probably
sitting here saying all this stuff
they're probably sitting back in their
offices going like you have no idea yeah
I'm sure that's right and then also the
opposite is somehow probably right like
you know maybe with all their
information they actually uh don't know
what's going on either yeah right or
remember wmds that they're in Iraq yeah
well were they really or were they not
or was that just lie to us it was a
psyop to convince America the American
people to support the war just like the
Gulf of Tonkin yeah no they knew there
was no wmds there was uh weapons
inspectors that came out and they were
silenced they were ignored by the media
they were gagged by of course the
federal government there was individuals
the only chemical weapons that Iraq had
was the ones that the United States sold
to them when they were at uh war with
Iran and they were and the US government
was was financing both sides of that
conflict both sides of that war and they
knew there was strategic papers out
there showing specifically you overthrow
the government of Iraq you're going to
have Sunni wahhabists take over the area
you're going to have massive of
sectarian violence you're going to have
Iran's fear of influence be expanded and
growing in the region which is not for
the American strategy which is to align
themselves with Saudi Arabia and the
sunnis so this was a recipe for disaster
and they knew this they had it all
outlined they knew hey we're going to be
hitting a beehive here and causing
problems for the next few decades ah
screw it we're gonna do it anyway the
political policy papers were all there
everything was lined up I was screaming
about this I was there you know I was
saying this is absolutely crazy this is
insane there's no wmds this is just the
project for a New American Century
realized in real life
you're on the same age as you know like
me and Luke I think I think me I think
he might be the youngest person here but
like 36 what do you got 36 but your
birthday's in August March and then Luke
when's your July you guys all 36
shout out to the 36 year olds out there
but I'm bringing this up because I'm
curious of you know back during the the
Loose Change era the Ron Paul Revolution
were you following that stuff oh yeah I
was a big Grandpa guy in 0.708 yeah and
I I assume like many others that leads
you to this position right now but I was
just wondering I mean I'm I'm wondering
I mean I definitely would have preferred
John McCain to Barack Obama really oh
yeah I see Mr I see quite a bit of
difference between them but zooming out
not as much difference as I would have
liked and then you had Ron Paul who was
basically like talking about the set of
questions that nobody was talking about
and
um I forget how he did in his primaries
I mean it wasn't it the revolution did
not happen right but it's still Galvin
has a lot of people like you said
earlier people believed in it and I
think he actually got
did he get like 10 New Hampshire or
something they cheated him they cheated
him in so many different ways especially
when it came to the polls especially
when it came to the corporate media
coverage I remember following that they
won't they wouldn't donation yeah they
screwed them over as John McCain was
literally singing songs about bombing
Iran so and also we have to understand
what happened with Barack Obama was a
direct result because of the mistakes
not mistakes but because of the
destruction of the United States caused
by George W Bush George W Bush was put
in a position of power he abused that
power he destroyed the American
Constitution he destroyed the American
economy and because of that we had a
cultural pushback just like we did
during Vietnam and the JFK assassination
where of course we had the leftists
become more prominent mainly because in
my opinion according to Bush
overreaching doing too much and becoming
a totalitarian leader which he was I
thought Obama was an example of like
hoping that we can put an innocent
charismatic guy in Power and hoping that
he'll save us like a superhero and like
he gets in and gets co-opted like
everyone else in that position when
reality we need a ground up movement and
he promised like I'll be there for you
and I think had we done a ground up
attempt at like some sort of Internet
economic Revolution that he wouldn't
have said no he would have sat by and
let it happen like he was he was looking
to do it but he couldn't do it from the
office there's too much that's the
fascinating thing about Obama is he ran
on Hope and change and it's supposed to
be discontinuous from Bush right and he
he effectively harnessed voters
dissatisfaction and I'm something new
and and actually his administration
represented stasis and continuation and
lock-in and Wall Street got even richer
and the Patriot Act got even more
fortified you thought drone strikes
under Bush were remarkable well Obama
just you know just they called him pedal
to the medal on that oh bomber and you
they called him deporter in Chief
Patrol guys on uh on the campaign they
would say you know Trump was great solid
a but then they'd say not to be partisan
about it like Obama like B Biden F in
terms of how these administrations
supported us right like Obama actually
understood it and go back to an Obama
speech from 08 or 09 it's like he sounds
like a right-winger on immigration he
says well obviously a country has
borders and if you just let anyone in
you don't know who's coming in then you
can't have a country you know it's like
wow you say that now and wow you're a
bigot but that was Barack Obama and oh
wait I'm not sure if he believed it but
he knew the politics of the time were
such that he had to say that I would
love to get just to talk to Barack in a
room with no satellite phones beaming in
and listening and here like you know how
co-opted did you get dude I know that
Michelle was trying to do the let's move
campaign get off sugar it was sugar is
bad for you let's move and cut sugar out
of our diet and then the sugar industry
came in it's like no no no let's make it
an exercise campaign not diet so I was
like okay now let's move is now an
exercise campaign sugar industry you're
back in back in business okay Katie
Couric does a documentary better than
ever right didn't the let's move
campaign it's like they they you know
saturated fat is bad we're gonna ban
this two percent milk from schools and
instead they introduce like strawberry
flavored skim milk which is like cancer
and you know tons of sugar but hey it
has no fat high fructose corn syrup and
Seed oils good intentions can actually
backfire surprise thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time